GAME FOR THE THIRD TIME,
SHORTHANDED AND THE RED WINGS
ARE GOING TO TRY AS RAYMOND BACK
TO SEIDER, POINT STREAK LAST
SEASON.   RIGHT IN FRONTT'S GOI
CHALLENGE, BUT THE RED WINGS
HAVE COME BACK ANDND'T THINK TH
CHALLENGE THAT.
>> Ken: NOT THAT YOU AND I HAVE
BEEN NECAS IN
AND WITH DETROIT KIND OF
MOMENT.
BACK TO THE SHOOT.
HE'S CENTER ICE, BEHIND THE
DEFENSE, AND H AND LARKIN INTER
ALONE, OH, A
OESTERLE.
AND HE'S RIGHT IN, SAVE MADE BY
NEDELJKOVICY LET HIM GO.   STIC
I DON'T KNOW.  ST.
>> Mickey: I THINK I HEARD
NICE JOB DOWN LOW.
OH,
ABLE TO FIND VELENO,'S RIGHT IN
AND A SAVE MADE BY RAANT
>> BOY, THOSE FACE-OFFS, SUCH
THE FAR SIDE.
NO CHANCE FOR YOUR G UP TO SHOO
AND LARKIN IT BACK, RAYMOND
IN AND CLEARED A A GREAT
FRESHMAN, LUCAS RAYMOND WHO END
THIS ONEE TIED FOR THE MOST TO
EXTRA
LOOKS FOR THE SHOT.
AT THE GOAL POST,
SAVE BY RAANTA.
>>>> IS
ROLLING, ROGO.
AND A SAVE MADE OFF  GOOD SAVE.
RAANTA GOT OVER.   RED WINGS WI!